six months of baseball and the red sox
season arrives at game 162 and it
doesn't get simpler than this the red
sox win and they take the number one
wild card and that means they will play
again at fenway park red sox tied with
the yankees going into play today
seattle and toronto one game back and
still alive and chris sale goes for the
sox today alex sevilla gets set to catch
his final game in the major leagues
while joao nadon is about to throw his
first major league pitch
took a little bit off swinging a miss
gonna be authenticated as well as the
first strikeout of the major league
career of joanne o'donnell what a
breaking ball that was first sale 5-1
era of 290. cut on and missed he put him
away at 95. thomas down swinging in
there strike three back-to-back case
from the lefty
swung on and missed 94 miles an hour he
strikes out the side chris sale out of
the gate rather quickly
the ovation
is a standing ovation
for nationals first baseman ryan
zimmerman
listen to the crowd roar
as everyone stands and applause
and he takes his helmet off and waves it
to the crowd and how about
christian vasquez the catcher walking
out of the grandson in front of home
plate
and faced home plate
until ryan zimmerman said okay
and now home plate umpire fielding
culberth is dusting off a clean home
play i think zim needs a a moment i
think he's a little emotional right now
we don't know if it's his final game
ever but it is 1799.
fell off the bag at second one two
coming
and struck him out
jordy mercer a solo homer in this series
he's over three career against sale
well hit left center gap the nets are
going to take the lead
bell scoring
mercer second rbi against boston
this weekend
one-nothing washington
second with one out to run in
oh
you're just worried that he's hurt
god forbid
he just sort of crumbled what gave on
him it's just everything gave they
started to push off and then the front
foot his right foot didn't well he
dragged the
lead shoe
on the ground instead of planting it
right
and that caused the tumble
that's frightening
and right back to the breaking ball and
he got him he struck him out
number five for sale
as he gets it over quickly he does swing
the bat there he strikes out they get a
first run of the ball game one to
nothing washington
breaking ball escobar gets a piece of it
it's another hit
with two strikes
the nets are in business
bell he's got another hit
thomas had to hold up to make sure it
cleared the infield oh here we go and
the bases are loaded for employee
number 11. there we go
that's one way to get an rbi
two-nothing nationals and he's walked
two men in the inning three in the game
unheard of zimmerman with the rbi yeah
really not even close and uh
the hook is out
that's going to do it for chris sales
salomora replaces him
and a hornet's nest
all loaded up with one down and we'll
have more in a moment but to me
chris sale you know that's
a four pitch walk with the bases loaded
unheard of right to short that's out
number one that's out number two and
good work by salomora the double play
with the bases loaded to escape it
rafaela base hit second inning
shout out to center field that's deep
that's carrying back there she's gone
and there's an answer rafael dever's
number 37. he clocks it and the red sox
get on the scoreboard that'll make it
2-1 it only traveled 432 yeah ask and
you sal received and he touched that off
again base hit
escobar was shaded way up the middle
thomas with the bare hand gets it back
in now they've got the runner hung up
zimmerman made a tough pick up mercer
runs him back pickle now zimmerman
chases him escobar's gonna run him down
boy alex verdugo went too far and lane
thomas picked the ball up with his bare
hand got it back in and he's got about a
half dozen assists
as a net center fielder look at these
fans you think they want action jd
martinez we're just taking a look at
this
something up with him with that foot or
that leg
it would appear
jd did not bat in the previous inning
he's been in right field he was on base
with the hit
by pitch first time up but you wonder
or we're hearing that he tripped over
second base
coming out to the outfield you'll see it
right here
good sex is stumbling today we saw chris
sales stumble
yeah we did and
he's gonna go out the right field
temper
pitcher drops it throws to first gets it
out but the nets score
3-1
[Applause]
big spot now with two outs for alex
avila
alex seville is going to drag in two
soto bell
both scoring
the nationals lead 5-1
that was cool
[Applause]
and his last big league game alex avila
it's a double to drive in two here in
the fifth and make it five to one
iglesias is on deck he's gonna hit for
jd martinez we saw jd with that stumble
over the bag when he was going out to
play his position in right field and now
he's coming out of the game he'll throw
him a strike and a base hit
iglesia is coming off the bench he's got
a knock and a payoff pitch to verdugo
into right for a base hit
iglesias stops at second back-to-back
singles
with one away in the sixth
one strike pitch to the sox catcher
he chops that one up the middle behind
the bag and a play and did not get him
as the run comes in to score
they went for the out at second and
iglesias touches home plate to make it
5-2 first and second in front of rafael
devers this is it i'm telling you this
is it
base hit into right center field
schwarber coming around he will score
easily
down to third safely is xander bogarts
and the red sox have strung together
three consecutive hits to pull to it in
two
a ball and a strike back to that cutter
i think
he jumped on it there's a shot to the
alley that's all the way to the wall
xander is in
denver's coming in he's going to score
verdugo with a stinging shot has tied
the game at 5-5
he did he did it three for four on the
day couldn't come at a better time
red sox come back from a 5-1 deficit to
tie it here his third hit today rocking
the baby
why did zimmerman
took the field alone
josh bell came out to hug him
the red sox have come out of their
dugout then that's out of theirs
davey martinez limps
to hug his
favorite net
it's the best choreography in the
history of this ballpark
is next he has three hits including a
home run today yeah he's the man
there's a shot that one driven to center
field backing up backing up it's gone
home run
there's finnegan's rainbow right there
i told you he's the man
is he the man or what rafael devers
center field and the red sox are in
front
split me that's what i'm talking about
nothing but split fingers and he gets
one up and it's a no doubter again
[Applause]
goodness gracious rafael devers his
second home run today
and the boston red sox have the lead in
the ninth inning
and the red sox will be the number one
wild card and will take on the new york
yankees at fenway
on tuesday
and pavetta coming out of the bullpen
looking for a save from pavetta
oh and two
on soto and here comes
struck him out and the red sox have won
the top wild card position they knock
off washington they sweep the series 7-5
the final
and the celebration begins here in d.c
nothing but drama forever this this
weekend series against washington was
everything you can ask for the red sox
are right where they want to be
hosting the wildcard against the yankees
tuesday night